[Music]
we're used to seeing Milly Bobby Brown
looked like that but now she's totally
changed her hair and twice in less than
a week I wanted to do something
different
first she went totally blonde the yfv
salon in Miami posted these pics to
their Instagram and people couldn't help
but notice the look looks a lot like 11
does during her stranger things makeover
in season 1 wow she looks great
this week though she also went darker
and longer this stylist posted these
shots of Milly with long ombre
extensions now Milly hasn't actually
posted any photos of herself so it's
hard to know which look she's rocking
right now but regardless we know she
loves changing up her look in 2017 she
said this I'm loving this hair talked to
me about this chain my amazing style
hair stylist like he he just you know
he's so incredible and I feel like we
just we wanted to do something crazy and
and creative and I feel like you know we
accomplished that and not just for
herself but for 11 do I think that an
Evans has storyline goes really really
funny and it's a very funny first - a
funny story line we're very excited for
it